etter s'est pas au moment où on est
dedans qu'il faut s'en préoccuper
je pense que la france se doit plus que
jamais de se doter de moyens militaires
pour sa défense pour sa sécurité
le président trump a déclaré à plusieurs
reprises notamment à bruxelles que
c'était aux européens de se prendre en
charge de dépenses et pour leur défense
eh bien je pense que la conséquence de
tout ça c'est il faut que le concept de
sécurité commune en europe avance et que
nous fassions tous un effort il faut
moins de diplomatie des déclarations et
un peu plus de diplomatie de l'action
[Musique]
oui
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
la haut commissaire de l'onu aux droits
de l'homme dénoncent la répression en
biélorussie la situation du pays
inquiète aussi l'union européenne
vendredi une réunion extraordinaire de
ses ministres des affaires étrangères
aura lieu à la contestation post
électoral se poursuit avec une troisième
nuit manifestations contre la réélection
d'alexandre loukachenko à la tête du
pays à deux pluie dimanche en compta
morts et 6000 personnes arrêtent au
liban après la double explosion du 4
août qui a fait 171 morts et 6000
blessés l' enquête se poursuit le
parquet convoque vendredi à des
ministres et ex ministre et deux jours
après la démission du gouvernement à la
pression du peuple ne faiblit pas avec
une 4e d'une manifestation à beyrouth
actrice politique humanitaire et
économique pour venir à son chevet le
fonds monétaire international demandent
la mise en oeuvre de réformes
dans toute l'europe le coc u19 ne
pouvait pas de répit en espagne une
deuxième vague arrive le pays est dans
une situation critique avec les plus
mauvais chiffres du continent dans ce
contexte le premier vaccin annoncée par
la russie suscite de nombreuses
réactions mitigées
l'om s appelle à la prudence moscou se
veut rassurant et puis nos manies la
vague de contestation contre le
président keïta s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui depuis plusieurs mois
l'opposition réclame son départ malgré
ses échecs
une médiation ouest africaine poursuit
ses efforts human rights watch dénonce
un usage excessif de la force le mois
dernier
[Musique]
il est 20h heure de paris bonsoir et
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur rt france et on débute avec
la situation en biélorussie qui inquiète
l'union européenne elle a convoqué une
réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères pour vendredi
sur place la contestation post
électorale continue même si les
autorités affirment qu'elle est en
déclin le pays a connu une troisième
nuit de manifestations contre la
réélection pour un 6ème mandat
d'alexandre loukachenko à la police dit
avoir tiré par arme à feu sur les
manifestants
l'un d'entre eux a été blessé depuis
dimanche plus de 6000 personnes ont été
arrêtées plusieurs photographes se sont
vu confisquer leurs clés usb et
endommager leurs appareils photo par les
forces de l'ordre
écoutez ces quelques réactions
nous sommes tous des lots russe comment
cela est il possible frapper votre
propre peuple
ce n'est pas juste
tir tir nous sommes juste en train de
parler nous sommes contre les résultats
de ces élections
ils ont été falsifiés alexandre
loukachenko ne semble pas disposé à
écouter les manifestants et il appelle
les biélorusses à se mettre au travail
écouter tous ceux qui veulent travailler
qui cherchent à travailler doivent avoir
un emploi et donc un salaire
ceux qui ne travaillent pas aujourd'hui
devrait faire l'objet d'une étude au cas
par cas et se voir offrir un emploi à
ces soi-disant manifestants sont des
gens qui ont tabassé criminelle et qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage
je voulais pas de travail alors va te
balader dans les rues et les avenues
c'est pourquoi je demande et je préviens
gentiment tout le monde
ceux qui ne travaillent pas doivent se
mettre au travail la boîte et les
réactions de la communauté
internationale se succèdent après
l'union européenne hier plusieurs
responsables politiques ont fait part
aujourd'hui de leur inquiétude face à la
répression des manifestations écouter le
chef de l'état fait part de sa très
grande préoccupation sur la situation en
biélorussie et la violence opposés aux
citoyens lors des élections il a
souligné la nécessité de retrouver la
voie du dialogue
nous avons assisté à une élection qui
nous préoccupaient beaucoup ne s'est pas
déroulé de manière libre et juste nous
soucions de cela parce que nous nous
associons profondément du peuple
bélarusse
comme je le dis en république tchèque
nous voulons que le peuple du bélarus et
les libertés qu'il réclame et qu'il
pense être dans son meilleur intérêt
les gens ont le droit de s'exprimer et
d'exprimer leur désaccord
a fortiori dans le contexte d'élections
quand les libertés démocratiques devrait
être maintenu et non supprimée mais pour
karine bechet goal of qu au professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou
les manifestants ne représentent pas la
majorité de la population
10 lorus écouter le problème c'est que
les inquiétudes maintenant de descendre
dans la rue à partir du moment où sur
des condamnés n'a pas été on peut pas
les appliquer quand même tout le peuple
biélorusse fois dans leur niche
quand on regarde la vidéo ne sont pas
des martin azerty deuxième chose il ya
quand même des choses assez étonnante
par exemple que la police dévolu s'est
arrêté d'un terreau que nier et arrêté
un homme qui d'ailleurs allé en
comportement extrêmement violent rap et
blessé des policiers et qui s'est
retrouvé avec 10000 dollars celui qu'ils
étaient en train de distribuer eux-mêmes
des récents mondiaux question qui se
pose est quel est la part des gens qui
réellement en ont marre de pêche qu ils
sortent et ceux qui sortent parce que
quelque chose qu'ils feront sauter sur
le scénario qui mêle la colère au liban
ne faiblit pas une semaine après le
drame de nouveaux affrontements ont eu
lieu entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre pour la quatrième nuit
consécutive selon un dernier bilan
la double explosion dans le port de
beyrouth a fait au moins 171 morts et
6000 blessés et près de 300 milles
libanais se retrouvent aujourd'hui sans
abri à les dégâts matériels sont
considérables le président michel aoun a
lui même indiqué que le coût de
l'explosion à dépasser les 15 milliards
dollars le liban qui espère toujours
l'aide du fmi met une condition la mise
en oeuvre de réformes le fonds monétaire
international
les réclame depuis le début des
négociations en mai dernier des mesures
qui concernent l'assainissement des
finances publiques l'adoption d'une loi
de contrôle des capitaux
et puis la restructuration de la dette
écoutez à ce propos gabriel colti style
et économistes
les prêts du fmi ne sont jamais gratuit
les autres jours des contreparties et
ses contreparties risque d'être très dur
pour le peuple libanais mais risque
d'être également defla gratis d'un
certain consensus qui a pu exister entre
les banques libanaises et et les
gouvernements les représentants de
l'état
ce que le fonds monétaire international
de souhaite et d'ailleurs de concert
avec avec le la france puisqu'il
présente à cran et que prévu en ce sens
ce sont des maisons c'est la mise en
fanfare en oeuvre par tant de réformes
et en particulier des réformes des
secteurs secteur financier le secteur
bancaire à la crainte d'une deuxième
vague épidémique en espagne le pays
affiche les pires chiffres de contagion
d'europe occidentale et se trouve dans
un état critique selon les experts tout
de suite les explications en images
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
et pour un philippe emmanueli médecins
français à barcelone les chiffres
données ne sont pas forcément les bons
écouter pourquoi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que ce chiffre aujourd'hui de
5000 cas qui est annoncée quotidien et
en partie faux puisque il comprend à la
fois les résultats qui sont déclarés en
termes de pcr et en termes de sérologie
le vrai chiffre de cas effectivement
diagnostiqué par pcr est aujourd'hui
d'environ 1800 c'est à dire qu'il est à
la hauteur du nombre de cas déclarés en
france servent dans un pays plus petits
milles et 2800 et ce qui fait monter et
obtenir ce chiffre de 5000
ce sont les autres résultats qui
s'agrège qui sont les résultats de
sérologie dont on sait qu'ils sont un
peu moins fiable pour certifier
effectivement par exemple la date de
contamination ou l'activité effective de
la contamination du coronavirus et le
maroc aussi voit son nombre de cas
fortement augmenté le pays a enregistré
près de 1500 nouvelles contaminations
lors des dernières 24 heures le bilan
est désormais de plus de 35 mille cas
confirmés depuis le mois de mars le
comité 19 a également fait 5 156 morts
au maroc c'est le sixième pays qui est
le plus touché la ligne et puis
troisième pays le plus touché d'amérique
latine le pérou voit son nombre de
patients atteints du coït 19 augmenter
chaque jour une situation désastreuse de
temps climat fait face à une forte
contestation des employés du secteur de
la santé
valentin carpentier
ils étaient des centaines réunis dans
les rues de lima dans l'espoir qu'une
main leur soient tendues au lieu de ça
les professionnels de santé péruviens
ont été reçus par des canons à eau
tous étaient rassemblés pour demander de
meilleures conditions de travail
alors que le pays subit une deuxième
bague de kobe de 19 maintenant avec la
pandémie
nous travaillons sans prime sans rien
nous n'avons plus la sécurité de
l'emploi alors que c'est ce que nous
demandons est ce dont nous avons le plus
besoin
une défaillance du système de santé qui
coûte cher au plan humain car depuis la
levée du confinement fin juillet la
situation ne s'est pas arrangée en
raison de l'engorgement des hôpitaux
les péruviens atteint du convive 19 sont
même contraints d'aller directement
s'approvisionner en oxygène nous
voulions économiser de l'argent alors
nous avons retiré de l'oxygène pour un
proche
et pendant que nous étions ici sa
saturation a commencé à baisser et il
était sur le point de nous quitter
honnêtement l'oxygène est très rare je
vous jure que nous avons parcouru
t'oublie mayer pour aller chercher de
l'oxygène pour quelques patients c'est
difficile de voir des gens pleurer
réclamer et supplier pour de l'oxygène
en parallèle aux rennais avec cinq cent
mille cas pour plus de 21 mille morts
le pérou est le neuvième pays le plus
touché au monde et la tendance ne semble
pas près de s'inverser
pire une enquête menée par le ministère
de la santé démontre que 30000 personnes
supplémentaires pourraient succomber aux
qu'ovide 19 dans le pays
les premiers pays au monde à donner son
feu vert à la production d'un vaccin
contre le coronavirus la russie qui
entame sa fabrication de masse une
vingtaine de pays auraient déjà passé
commande auprès de moscou
l'immersion tout de suite exclusive dans
le centre qui assurera son processus de
fabrication
les détails avec pierre jan masaryk
c'est dans ce laboratoire que spoutnik v
devrait être fabriquée en très grande
quantité
depuis l'annnonce de sa découverte par
la russie le vaccin suscite à la fois
beaucoup d'espoir dans la lutte contre
le coronavirus mais aussi un certain
scepticisme
le précieux remède a été approuvé par le
ministère russe de la santé
avant la phase iii des essais cliniques
soit le stade le plus avancé ce qui
n'entame pas la confiance des dirigeants
du centre de fabrication
il est certain que la vaccination
provoque la formation d'anticorps
spécifiques notamment de protection
on peut ajouter que durant la période de
vaccination des bénévoles
le titre d'anticorps a été suffisant
c'est ici que se déroule l'étape finale
de la fabrication au cours de laquelle
le vaccin est inspecté dans le cadre du
contrôle qualité
si les unités de vaccin parce
l'inspection elles sont ensuite
étiquetés et préparer pour être emballée
jusqu'à 120 mille flacons par jour sont
ainsi préparés une cadence infernale qui
vise à atteindre le milliard de doses
précommandée à travers le monde selon
les autorités russes
une vingtaine de pays se seraient déjà
manifestés pour acquérir spoutnik les et
je vous propose d'écouter maintenant un
peter smith il est professeur
d'épidémiologie tropicale à londres et
ex président du comité consultatif
mondial de l'om est sur la sécurité des
vaccins et pour l'huile annonce russe
est significative dans le sens où on a
conçu près de 150 vaccin sans qu'aucun
d'entre eux ne soient certifiés à ma
connaissance si l'accent russe est le
premier à être certifié il s'agit
vraiment d'une annonce importante
malheureusement nous ignorons pour
l'instant quelles données servent de
critères de certification
mais d'après ce que je vois il ya eu un
nombre relativement modeste de personnes
qui ont déjà reçu ce vaccin chaque fois
il est très difficile voire pratiquement
impossible de déterminer si un vaccin
est efficace et l'on pourrait même avoir
des réserves quant à l'innocuité d'un
vaccin
je pense par conséquent que nous avons
besoin de plus d'informations sur ce
vaccin et que nous devons demeurer
prudente concernant cette annonce
le chef de la diplomatie allemande a
exprimé son mécontentement à son
homologue américain en cause de
nouvelles menaces de sanctions contre un
port allemand de la baltique il est
reproché à berlin sa participation au
projet de gazoduc nord stream 2 à qui
achemine le gaz russe vers l'europe
malgré la pression de washington moscou
reste formel le projet se tiendra bel et
bien kirill kotick of le ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères raiko
masse est furieux en cause une lettre
envoyée la semaine dernière par trois
sénateurs américains qui menacent de
détruire financièrement le port allemand
2 à ce mythe sur l'île de rügen en mer
baltique
j'en ai parlé hier lors d'une
conversation téléphonique avec mike
pompéo et lui ai fait part de ma stupeur
et de mon mécontentement
pourquoi ça snit et bien c'est là que se
ravitailler le navire russe académique
cher ce qui qui posent actuellement les
dernier tronçon sous-marin du gazoduc
qui acheminera le gaz russe vers
l'europe
le fameux projet nord stream ii financé
pour moitié par l'entreprise russe
gazprom l'autre moitié étant prise en
charge par cinq compagnies d'énergie
européenne dont le français angie le
projet de gazoduc north stream 2 devrait
doubler le débit actuel qui est de 55
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par an
du 'pipeline' north stream entrer en
service en 2011 et qui relie l'allemagne
à la russie en passant par le fond de la
mer baltique et pour les etats-unis cela
signifie perdre en influence dans la
région le gaz russe est beaucoup plus
accessible à l'europe une livraison par
gazoduc c'est quand même beaucoup plus
pratique une livraison de gaz naturel
liquéfié par bateau il est aussi
beaucoup moins cher et comme washington
ne peut globalement pas faire grand
chose
les sanctions économiques entrent en jeu
sauf que l'allemagne a rappelé qu'elle
avait peut-être un peu son mot à dire au
nom de la libre concurrence et que sa
coopération dans le projet nord stream 2
était avant tout commercial business is
business
aussi le sujet a été évoqué lors de la
rencontre de heiko maas avec le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov lors de sa visite à moscou ce
mardi 11 août
la réponse russe ne s'est pas fait
attendre il s'agit encore une fois pour
les états unis d'imposer leur propre
volonté sans aucun recours à la
diplomatie
washington a clairement fait savoir
qu'il ferait tout son possible pour
empêcher le projet nord stream 2 parce
qu'il serait soit disant préoccupée par
l'indépendance énergétique de l'europe
c'est son choix en revanche l'allemagne
a pour sa part
fait le choix de participer au projet je
pense qu'elle a raison les participants
au projet nord stream 2 sont déterminés
dans le fait que le projet sera achevé
et il ya toutes les raisons de croire
que cela se produira dans un avenir
proche si berlin principal bénéficiaire
du projet voit dans le gazoduc russe une
source d'énergie stable
les etats-unis et d'autres pays
européens ukraine pologne pays baltes
lui reproche de permettre au gaz russe
de contourner l'ukraine ce qui priverait
kiev d'importantes recettes de transit
alors que l'ukraine ait soutenu
politiquement et militairement par
washington à la mi juillet mike pompéo
avait ouvert la voie à des sanctions
plus dures pour empêcher la mise en
service de ce projet donald trump de son
côté a promulgué fin décembre une loi
imposant des sanctions contre les
entreprises associées à la construction
de nord stream 2 estimant que cet
ouvrage allait accroître la dépendance
des européens au gaz russe et ainsi
renforcer l'influencé de moscou
mais pour l'instant c'est un peu comme
brasser de l'air la grèce avec ses
relations tendues avec la turquie
demande à l'union européenne d'organiser
un sommet d'urgence les rapports entre
les deux pays se sont encore dégradées
hier avec l'arrivée d'un navire
d'exploration gazière turc dans une zone
située entre la crète et la chypre et
chypre une zone riche en gisements
gaziers dont l'appartenance grecque est
contesté par la turquie
le vieux différend a empiré avec
l'accord maritimes turques aux libyens
de décembre 2019
écoutez les ministres des affaires
étrangères grec et turc
khartoum et chauffage nous disons
clairement que la grèce défendra sa
souveraineté et ses droits souverains
quai paquet gars qui capteront kalume
into nous appelons la turquie a quitté
sans délai le plateau continental
grecque nous sommes pleinement
déterminés à poursuivre nos recherches
sismiques nos efforts d'exploration
nous défendrons jusqu'au bout les droits
de la turquie et des chypriotes turcs en
méditerranée orientale et à chypre et
nous ne ferons aucune concession et pour
un claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
le partage des eaux de la méditerranée
va être le sujet de tensions entre la
turquie et la grèce dans les semaines à
venir le partage de ces eaux qui peut se
faire en fonction les règles du droit de
la mer
ou des lignes d'équidistance ou du
plateau continental va provoquer des
conflits alors actuellement en effet on
assiste à un conflit qui grandit entre
la turquie et la grèce puisque la
turquie a envoyé un navire pour faire
des de l'exploration sismique comme on
dit c'est à dire faire exploser des
charges au fond de la mer pour voir en
fonction de la résonance s'il y a des
poches de gaz ou des poches
hydrocarbures et ce bateau de recherche
sismique est accompagné de plusieurs
frégates militaires
on a parlé de cette frégate militaire ce
qui en effet dépasse un peu la
protection est normal que l'on peut
accorder à pato de recherche 18 par
ailleurs les grecs disent que ce bateau
et sur leur plateau continental elle et
pas que par conséquent il n'a rien à y
faire
la direction le mali où la vague de
contestation contre le président ibrahim
boubacar keïta se poursuit ces
mobilisations encore aujourd'hui à
bamako comme hier lorsque des milliers
de manifestants sont redescendus dans la
rue après une trêve à cette semaine un
médiateur est arrivé à bamako sans
succès et puis sachez que le fg human
right watch dénonce un usage excessif de
la force le mois dernier dans la
capitale
waleed bin ans
[Applaudissements]
une pluie fine des vuvuzelas qui résonne
de la musique est toujours le même
refrain
nous sommes là pour demander tout
simplement la démission du président de
la république de son régime tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont échoué
plus de co2 que nous avons durant ces
sept ans durée seiler année des gestions
calamiteuses
catastrophique du pays de gao et kidal
de taoudénit de tombouctou
mp partout dit non on s'est donné la mer
pour dire qu'on malia pas de problème
mais c'est des politiciens qui prennent
des problèmes une reprise des
manifestations dans le calme après une
trêve entamée le 21 juillet pour
célébrer une fête musulmane
pour rappel le week-end du 10 juillet
des heurts entre manifestants et forces
de l'ordre avaient coûté la vie à au
moins 11 personnes des milliers de
manifestants aujourd'hui inflexible aux
appels au dialogue lancés par la
communauté des états d'afrique de
l'ouest son médiateur goodluck johnatan
s'est rendu lundi à bamako pour
rencontrer des principaux membres de
l'opposition dont l'imam mahmoud dicko
[Musique]
les manifestations en elle-même ne
résolvent pas le problème ce sont les
discussions les négociations qui
permettent de les résoudre
maintenant que les manifestations nous
ont permis de connaître les problèmes
prenons la peine de nous asseoir pour en
débattre calmement la cedeao prennent
pour un gouvernement d'union nationale
cinquante postes pour le parti au
pouvoir 30 pour l'opposition et 20
autres qui reviendrait aux membres de la
société civile et à des organismes
professionnels une éventuelle
composition qui ne satisfait pas
l'opposition déjà méfiante s'agissant de
la prise de fonction des neuf nouveaux
membres de la cour constitutionnelle
une composition qui a été validé par la
cedeao et le président ibrahim boubacar
kéïta dit ib kg objectif c'est la raison
pour laquelle abou eich chine
c'est à dire essaie de le prendre le
temps que se peut
aux attentes aux besoins politiques mais
par le doigt
et bien que le doigt mardi l'imam mamoud
diko acclamé par la foule a demandé à la
france de ne pas interférer dans la
politique malienne en soutenant le
premier ministre bouboule cissé sens
pour leur donner plus d'explications à
cette méfiance à l'égard de paris
et puis en côte d'ivoire cette sortie de
simone gbagbo l'épousé de l'ancien
président laurent gbagbo actuellement en
belgique elle dénonce la candidature
d'alassane ouattara à la présidentielle
est sans surprise est la deuxième
vice-présidente du front populaire
ivoirien la jugent anticonstitutionnelle
elle demande d'amnesty pour laurent
gbagbo une amnestie cugn a déjà accordé
alassane ouattara à demain les jeunes
militants ivoiriens appellent à
manifester contre sa candidature simone
gbagbo a pris la parole hier lors d'une
conférence de presse à abidjan
et de rappeler que la candidature du
musée à la fin de ouattara est un tea
party soleil
nous le savons tous d'ailleurs cette
candidature jean de la constitution
on a sonné sous quelques formulées par
les auteurs de ce texte la candidature
de monsieur alassane ouattara n'est pas
recevable c'est à ce qu'il doit être
rien de plus le chef de l'état ne peut
pas se dit tout de valamas retour en
france et plus précisément à palavas
station balnéaire dans l'hérault un
collectif s'est formé pour dénoncer la
délinquance qui sévit d'été une
manifestation à d'ailleurs été organisée
vendredi dernier explications d'hervé
grand champ et de cyrielle benavides
bulbul lyon palavas et ses flots
d'incivilité la station balnéaire qui
compte 6000 habitants permanents a vu
cet été sa fréquentation augmenter de
30% accueillant 80 milles vacanciers et
parmi eux certains ne se gênent pas pour
multiplier les actes de délinquance
aujourd'hui à palavas on n'envoie plus
nos enfants acheter le pain parce que de
peur qu'il se fasse agresser ou volé le
soir on n'ose même plus se promener
parce que ben si on n'ose un peu le
regard on se fait agresser verbalement
ou physiquement
depuis le début de la saison c'est des
coucous de coups des coups de couteau
deux agressions verbales c'est des vols
cartes bleues téléphone portable et
ainsi de suite
vendredi 7 août 300 manifestants du
collectif stop tout n'est pas permis à
palavas se sont rassemblés pour dénoncer
l'insécurité grandissante et lancé un
cri d'alarmé à destination du maire de
la ville
c'est la cinquième manifestation que
nous faisons et parce que nous en avons
marre des rodéos nocturnes des
agressions verbales des cambriolages qui
ont lieu là de régulièrement depuis les
voitures qui se sont vandalisés bella
voilà vous êtes sur le boulevard où ce
défi de tout des rodéos du matin à
partir de 13 et 14 1 km jusqu'au soir
22h30 avant a juste après le confinement
on va dire que ça commençait ça démarre
et même pendant le confinement je dirais
les jeunes venaient ils viennent ils
prennent des ballons et des petites
capsules et puis ce shoot avec toute la
journée du matin au soir
ils prennent les voitures ensuite avec
et il jette tous leurs déchets un peu
partout dans palavas après de multiples
menaces d'habitants souhaitant quitter
la ville si rien ne changeait le maire
ait l'air de palavas-les-flots christian
jeanjean a réagi ce lundi
il a donc signé un arrêté pour fermer
les plages de la commune de 23 heures à
6 heures du matin jusqu'au 15 septembre
les restaurateurs ou autres exploitants
qui travaillent sur ces mêmes plages ne
sont eux pas concernés
pas forcément de quoi endiguer toute la
délinquance estivale mais au moins
permettre aux vacanciers séjournant dans
les résidences et campings aux alentours
de dormir sur leurs deux oreilles et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france à douter
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus titré
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île